hi everyone welcome to the daily
homeroom live stream style here from
khan academy for those of you all who
are new to this this is a live stream
that we've been doing every day since
we've had these global school closures
just as a way to stay connected
obviously khan academy we our whole team
we were trying to put out resources
starting in early learning with khan
academy kids all the way through
elementary middle and high school and
even early college to keep you learning
but we also want to provide more
supports we've been running parent
webinars teacher webinars this homeroom
live stream uh where we're going to have
really interesting guests including
today i'm especially excited about but i
do want to give my a standard
announcement reminding folks that we are
a not-for-profit we only can exist
because of philanthropic donations we're
running at a deficit even before covet
hit and now with kovid we're seeing our
traffic 3x of what it typically is uh we
are trying to do more more programs and
and ways to support you so if you're in
a position to do so please think about
donating i want to give special thanks
to several corporations that have
stepped up really in record time to
support this effort bank of america that
first weekend when they saw that we
needed they stepped up to help us out
google.org att fastly and novartis thank
all of them uh and even with their
significant support we still need more
help so if you represent a corporation
please talk to us and if you're just an
individual donor that still makes a huge
huge huge uh difference for our ability
to serve tens of millions of folks
around the world
so with that i am super excited to
introduce our guest angela duckworth
in certain circles she is a mega star i
would say i've known angela uh for many
years i think we ran into each other at
a conference in canada uh this was like
eight nine nine or ten years ago uh
eight or nine years ago uh but uh
then i even then i knew angela was on on
to something and since then i think her
her notoriety has just exploded because
the things she talks about are so
relevant to education i think especially
relevant to the time that we're dealing
with right now so angela thank you for
joining us
thank you sal and i'm gonna tell you a
secret you didn't just run into me i
actually flew to canada because i knew
someone told me that you were gonna be
and i
ran into you
but not by accident so i was stalking
you
that's well you see this is how the ti
the tables have turned because now i i
kind of stalk you
he just emails me it's a lot easier for
me to like fly to canada
exactly i didn't
so so i'm i'm glad that we are mutually
mutually stalking each other and i'm
gonna i'm gonna start off the
conversation but i do wanna encourage
everyone who's watching on youtube and
facebook uh put questions in there for
angela and you're gonna learn a lot more
about her areas of expertise if you
don't already know of of them but i i
will start angela
you're known
you're one of really a handful of i
would say pioneers or leaders in this
field of mindset research and you're
really known for grit
defining it in more precise terms so
just you know explain what mindset
research is and your view on it
especially relative to grit
the the term mindset has caught on i i
have to think that it's got to be almost
the maybe the most commonly understood
new scientific discovery in psychology
and uh
among among non-psychologists right
among parents and and kids and and
educators so what is mindset your
mindsets are beliefs that you have about
about the world or about human nature
that
drive so much of your behavior they may
not be beliefs that you
think about actively but they're very
powerful and in particular carol dweck
at stanford our common friend and really
my hero
she's worked her whole life on something
called growth mindset your beliefs about
your intelligence and you can either
have a growth mindset
which is you know the belief that
intelligence is malleable that your
abilities can change or you can have a
fixed mindset which is the belief that
they can't change that you know you are
who you are who you are you're either a
math person or not you're a natural
athlete or not um and uh in my research
on grit which is
passionate and persevering effort
towards long-term goals i find and i
think our early work with carol but in
subsequent studies also kids who have a
growth mindset about intelligence tend
to become grittier and then those
increases in grit tend to lead to
increases in growth mindset so there's a
kind of virtuous cycle when a kid really
believes that their abilities can change
they're more likely to persevere to try
hard at things which then reinforces
that belief
and just to make sure i understand these
because i often say these in the same
sentence and they are very closer in the
growth mindset is
i believe that i can do more i just have
to step out of my comfort zone and and
apply myself and if i fail at something
it's not a judgment on some type of
innate ability it's it's it's a moment
to learn from while grit is that ability
to stick to it
so that yeah i would say great
i mean great grit is a behave your grit
is like doing it right and and mindset
might be why you're doing it right so
the mindset is like the underlying
belief that would motivate a certain
pattern of behavior that that i would
describe as grit and and let me just say
because you know my kids are still
teenagers and um you know i'm sure a lot
of people have kids who are even younger
than than ours um i think that it's not
just when i think of grit i i don't
think just of like working hard it's
also loving what you do it's also being
intrinsically motivated over long
periods of time so um that's just a part
of of grit that i hope you know we can
talk about this conversation because i
don't want parents to get the message
that like the only thing kids need to do
is develop a work ethic they also have
to develop interests um loves passions
yeah and that's i think a good segue i
mean you know you're a professor of
psychology at the university of
pennsylvania you've been doing research
for a while you have a best-selling book
named not a surprise grit
[Laughter]
no imagination there on the title no no
the power of passion and perseverance i
think you know a question that a lot of
parents are asking my wife asked asked
me to ask you this when she saw that i
was walking into the walk-in closet to
interview you right now and it's a
question that has been coming up
throughout the school closures is that
there's a lot of resources out there
there's khan academy we've put out daily
schedules
but what is tangible advice for
parents teachers or students for
themselves to have that grit to be able
to
act on that growth mindset so to speak
so i think that uh not only for grit but
for lots of other things that we would
love our kids to develop as they grow
older um the combination of challenge
and support is magical and and if you
ask the question like what what are good
parents right like what does the science
of parenting say there's now decades of
research on parenting styles and the the
style of parenting that is the best
really i mean i can just say that flat
out it's the best your kids will be
happier they'll be more socially uh
adjusted but they'll also be
more accomplished like it's this
combination of being very
uh supportive but also being demanding
so you could say it's tough love now why
do i bring that up now in the middle of
the covid crisis because um because kids
are being challenged so their their
challenges have been um i think in all
cases and in many different ways raised
right now the question is like how as
parents can you meet that with increased
support um not trivial because we're
under our own stress etc but if you ask
the question to me like where does
psychological growth come from it comes
from this combination of like i'm being
asked to do something i can't yet do but
there's a floor beneath me there's a
foundation there's unconditional support
there's khan academy there you know
there are people who will help me you
know uh like make a schedule so i can go
on khan academy so so i think parents
can respond to this um crisis by in some
ways thinking of it as an opportunity
for their kids to develop these
qualities i call them character
strengths but you can call them sel
skills you can call them anything you
want um and and i really do think it's
it's not too pollyanna to say that it is
an opportunity to do all those things
and and what would you i mean one it's
it's impressive
that
there is i mean people have done the
research and they've been able to
categorize different styles and and this
what you're describing seems to be the
winning style and i'm personally
insecure to see how well i i hope no one
audits
give me a quiz or watch our family but
what what either from your research or
just as a parent that you've seen a good
practice i know y'all have done a lot of
research on interventions that can help
change uh people's mindsets
so i mean one i'd love to hear about
that research and then are there things
let's say hypothetically you were to
have a five and a half year old at home
or an eight-year-old
for example i don't know some people i
know and you know they they sometimes do
their work but they may be just doing
the minimum or sometimes they don't even
want to do that because they feel like
there's a little less accountability now
what does the research tell us and what
advice would you have for this
hypothetical person that i know
yeah well you know i have a
non-hypothetical 17 and as
non-hypothetical 18 year old but you
know
non-hypothetical five and a half year
old it sounds like on your end um so uh
i think one of the challenges of
parenting is to always be titrating to
where your kids are because when i said
that you need to be and i do believe
this like you need to be a demanding
parent i don't think kids i mean kids
need parents like they need us to ask
them to do things that they can't yet or
wouldn't on their own do
but the titration part is you know how
much is a stretch for your kid at this
particular moment in time and also at
this stage in their development it may
not be the same as it is even for
another kid in the same family so the
titration is how to
have your kids you know be challenged
but not too much um and so for example
you know when parents have a idealistic
goal of like their kids waking up making
a schedule for the day
sticking to the schedule you know
if if you start with a really
unrealistic goal um and you ask your kid
to get there um you know
immediately then then everybody just
gets discouraged and frustrated so one
piece of parenting advice is to take
stock of where your kids are and then
try to move like ten percent right as
opposed to like a hundred percent uh
towards something that you think is is
is better um and in general i find that
even adults procrastinate and don't do
well when they fail to break down big
goals into
smaller parts and then you know
make a more reasonable schedule about
you know how they're going to accomplish
you know
go down the list that's that's good
advice not just for parenting i mean i
just when while you were saying that i'm
just i'm i'm thinking about some of the
things that uh my wife and i have
attempted to do especially with some of
our younger kids i was like yeah maybe
if we just broke that down a little bit
more or just expected the first step of
that and then once i mean this is what
you do so well like by the way i mean i
will just say you have taught my kids
since
you know as you do so many kids around
the world like and and you may not have
known but the reason i flew to canada to
stalk you was because my kids were
spending so much time learning from you
on khan academy and i
you know just got really interested in
you know how psychologists like me might
might learn something from you and be
helpful and um and i think what you do
so well sal is you break things down
you know into
like parts so that so that like you can
swallow it kind of like a teaspoon at a
time and i think kids need our help as
parents to help them you know do that
and i sometimes feel like you know
parents might have unrealistic
expectations about you know like how
much progress they can you know expect
their kid to make when it comes to
self-regulation or time management or
discipline um
and it helps to remember that the great
teachers know to break things down
no well i think you're being very
flattering uh but i i think the point is
is right and i think as parents as much
as we try to be centered we can also
sometimes feel an urgency like wait i
heard someone else's kid has
you know has their whole schedule is
doing everything perfectly and then you
and you're probably doing the wrong
thing to your kid and you're trying to
get them from zero to that and that
other child probably isn't doing that
there's probably a little bit of
marketing involved there
we probably all have stories of you know
a child in my in my family was always
these like cousins that i have in boston
who you know were seemingly perfect and
actually now that i'm all grown up i
realize they were pretty much perfect
and they all became
you know like harvard professors but but
uh yeah wait you're the non-perfect one
in the family who knows what they're
doing i think i'm the black sheep um but
yes there's a very distinguished branch
of our family but i'm i'm not in it um
so so uh you know why do parents make
those comparisons i think they're just
you know they're kind of just come to
mind for the parent because they are you
know like oh that's the mental model i
have in my head so i'll just share it
with you but i don't think kids benefit
very much from those kinds of
comparisons and in general in schooling
i think and i'm thinking i know you have
a global audience but i'm thinking about
the american schooling system you know
it's a very kind of rank order like how
are you
relative to these other like 900 kids
who are your age and those kind of
comparisons like am i as smart as her am
i smarter than him i don't think they're
they're super beneficial most of the
time i think kids actually benefit from
making a different kind of comparison
which is how am i compared to how i want
to be compared to how i was
right and that's a comparison that you
can do something with and that's a
comparison that you know doesn't
diminish another person by yourself
making progress and you know when i
think about khan academy and and and
your whole philosophy you know you have
a book too which i read and you know
your whole philosophy of like how
education ought to work i really do
think it's you know it's you with you
and like how far you can go and not you
and your cousins in boston or you and
you know the
899 kids who are also in your graduating
class
and
i mean with that thought there's a ton
of questions coming in i want to get to
those questions but i'll ask one of my
last indulgent style questions which is
you've done a lot of research that you
can you can change people's mindsets i
mean tell us a little bit about some of
the research that
will give all of us a growth mindset
about changing our kids mindset about
grit
well i'll tell you about a big study
that was run recently and published in
nature
it was a huge scientific team led by
david yeager at ut austin and um also of
course carol dweck was involved i was
just one among many team members but
what it was was an experiment to see
whether we could increase growth mindset
in ninth graders all over
the united states and the experiment was
a success and if you ask the question
like what did you do how did you
increase growth mindset there were these
brief really i'm just you know
minutes long activities where students a
learned that lots of other kids around
their age you know also sometimes feel
stupid when they get something wrong and
they they can kind of slip into uh like
oh i'll never learn this um mode but
then they learned about the neuroscience
that's actually true that the brain is
plastic that there is tremendous growth
and when you do struggle and you make a
mistake and you look at it again that
your brain actually changes so for for
um for me when i think about this one of
the reasons why intelligence is a hard
thing to get kids to understand like
that it is mallee but it's because it's
invisible it's like it's it's in your
you know you can't see your brain right
whereas if you said to a kid like do you
think if you lifted all these weights
you know your biceps would get bigger
they would say like of course but but
intelligence is kind of behind you know
the forehead so you don't see it anyway
ninth graders learned about the modern
neuroscience of brain plasticity and
then the last thing that they did was
they actually wrote a letter to
other students that were you know for
example like a little younger than you
like what would you say how would you
summarize all this for them and i think
this um combination of feeling like oh i
hear the voices of other students who
you know can sometimes feel dumb when
they do something but then they learn to
not feel that way to understand mistakes
as growth and learning you get some
scientific evidence and then you are put
in the position of communicating that to
other students i i think it's it's quite
brilliant honestly and in this study uh
there were measurable increases in
mindset growth mindset and then also um
particularly for students who had uh
schools where the cultures supported it
there were uh also improvements in
grades
wow
just to make sure you should say test
scores i think they were so cool i
should like check on that i think it was
like math grades and test scores but no
but either way that that's very
compelling i mean is
are there are there ways for parents to
get that that intervention for either
themselves or their kids
yeah i'll make sure that you all have
the the hyperlink to the work and um the
some of this work was supported by the
mindset scholars network and you know
there there's there's a link where you
can actually get this also for educators
i mean i i'll make sure that you have
the right resources um and
finally i'll just say i think parents
should read carol's book i mean they
should read your book too they should
read lots of books but i think mindset
is a terrific and um it's a fast read
it's beautifully written
good advice so there's a lot of
questions here so from youtube joe asks
angela can you use grit to force
yourself to have a passion for something
you have little interest in for example
a job
no
if you want more than a one-word answer
i can i can elaborate but i don't think
that uh you can force yourself
uh to be passionate about things when i
measure intrinsic motivation feeling
genuinely curious about things and also
feeling like your work is aligned with
your personal values uh that is what's
correlated with grit not extrinsic you
know like i was coerced to do it or i'll
make a lot of money if i do it so i
think for um for me the advice would not
be to try to force yourself but actually
to
find if you're already an adult like to
find a job that is more closely aligned
with your developed interests and your
values and if you're still a kid i would
say you know the the the word you want
to use about with passion is develop i
think you want to develop passions that
are mature and so that requires you know
lots and lots of time you know doing
things becoming more and more and more
interested in them and committed to them
but i don't think it's a process of
forcing yourself or for for anybody else
to force you either
and this is really interesting because
so you know grit when people think of
the word just in the colloquial sense
they think of like being able to power
through pain
you can exhibit the qualities of grit
but by but it's not because you're
powering through pain it's because
you're intrinsically motivated in what
you're doing
yeah and i don't want to paint this like
you know look you work really hard sal i
work really hard i think there there are
parts of our day where we don't want to
do what we have to do but we have to do
it but but i would say about myself and
i'm sure that you would say right like
you love what you do you love what you
do and so yeah there's practice and
there's hard work and there's getting
over disappointment nobody loves doing
it but but overall you love what you do
and i think that's the part that's
missing in that syllable word that it
doesn't sound like it but when i when i
study it and when i find it in a really
high performer it's it's really always
there
you know i'll talk a hack that i think
is related to joe's question and i think
it's consistent with what you said but i
have no scientific backing other than my
n of one and what's going on in my own
bizarre head
which is one of my skills that that i
have and i'm quite proud of is i can
convince myself to be passionate about
almost anything and so
wait give me an example like oh almost
any you know well i mean a lot of people
in kane i mean they can hear it in my
voice sometimes in these videos like i'm
excited about the aldol reaction and
they're like why i was like well i don't
i won't even make the video until i am
excited about it because there is
something exciting you know in in
academics what i remind students is
almost everything is the culmination of
someone's life work
and they would have done they would have
killed to have the answers that you have
in your textbook or that are being
explained to you on a khan academy video
and that by itself makes it exciting uh
you know and even things as part of my
job that i aren't like my favorite thing
you know i love our auditors they're
great people but you know sitting in
like a meeting
about our audit report is it like you
know what i click my heels but i remind
myself no this isn't a very important
step in order for us to become a real
organization in order for us to serve
more people so i definitely do that that
i remind myself why what i'm doing
matters and uh you know i had a boss
that told me my first you know i was
working at a big company and there's
times where i was like oh it doesn't
matter if i show up or not i'm kind of a
cog in this big thing and he said look
you just have to show up and
make yourself and make the company
better off today than it was yesterday
and there's something about that that
made me feel very motivated about it and
i'm like oh yeah yeah i can get
passionate about that but i think we're
consistent as long as you can get
yourself authentically passionate
motivated then you can the grit will
will kind of happen or can happen
yeah and okay so uh so you said oh this
is your end of one like let me give you
a little science behind that so um when
you think about why you have to go to an
auditing meeting or thinking think about
kids doing their homework right i mean
so many kids feel like why am i doing
this this is totally pointless what
they're feeling is that there isn't any
purpose to their work there isn't any
like this is a means but what's the end
um and so what your maybe your boss did
and certainly what human beings do is
it's it's useful to think about your
goals hierarchically like you know why
am i on this video with khan academy
with sal khan it's like because actually
i believe that psychological science can
help kids thrive so for me
this time that we're spending together
has a purpose if a kid is doing their
homework and they see the point of doing
these you know practice problems like
and they see the point of this class
overall it's really like what you're
doing is you're helping them see the
kind of the goal that sits above this
goal like oh this is the reason why i'm
doing it the hierarchy makes sense to me
so i agree with you that sometimes we
forget and then we have to remind
ourselves and then it gives meaning and
purpose to something that otherwise
would be mundane um
but i guess i wouldn't go so far as
recommending to people that you could
make yourself passionate about
everything i don't think that's what
you're saying but because i don't think
i don't think it's possible for people
to like really literally be randomly
assigned to a job and then just be you
because i i think about your life sal
and i think
you know uh
obviously it took an unexpected turn
when you left you know your career track
and you became who you are today but i
also have to believe that you know i
couldn't just like have randomly
selected any career path for you that
you you would be working as hard as you
are now uh for for khan academy
oh for for sure for sure i mean there's
definitely an optimization when i have a
choice i definitely am optimizing for
what
fills my bucket so to speak and i'm
learning about a five-year-old language
and what feels right
my bucket uh but no it's an interesting
you know i have to ponder that i have to
meditate on that more to what am i
living in my own delusion or or not
i i think you i think you've made it
here's why i just taught this
undergraduate class called grit lab um
uh to 60 undergraduates at my university
university of pennsylvania and when i
had to summarize the entire class in the
last hour of the class i said all right
three things choose easy
work hard pay it forward and the choose
easy was about choosing things that
you're naturally or intrinsically
interested in they they feel like they
resonate with your values you're good at
them or like i actually think that's the
part that you did you chose something
that you're very very good at and
committed to it resonates with your
deepest values you love learning you
probably love teaching
okay then what's number two what number
two is work hard and number two is you
know what the audit is part of running
khan academy you know what raising money
is part of khan academy i'm sure you
don't like that either
you know what like doing whatever it is
that you need to do and i think that's
where you're using these like mental
hacks to kind of like get yourself to be
excited about an audit or and that's the
part where you do need to use discipline
and strategies to to work hard and by
the way the third part is pay it forward
right so you know for every
good person um in life you know that
means uh
you know doing things for other people
but but i do think that sometimes young
people get these confused and they think
they should choose hard and that the
work should be easy but like no no you
choose things that are kind of fluent
and fluid for you and then there's
always going to be friction and that's
when you have to learn all these ways to
work hard
does that make any sense
no i mean it made up it made a ton of
sense it was a fascinating conversation
and you know whenever we're having these
good conversations the time goes by far
faster than i would like i hope we have
more time to have a uh this conversation
because i think we're just getting
started and maybe we have time for one
more uh question from youtube sanjeev
kumar asks can anyone develop grit at
any age or is it more specific for
children and young adults
i really do believe that one of the
great lessons of psychological science
over the last few decades is
that we are remarkably
malleable in other words carol dweck is
not only right about intelligence but
about um pretty much every other facet
of human nature and i'm not saying that
you can metamorphose into like some
completely different human being in in a
day but i do think yeah you can develop
growth mindset you can develop grit you
can become a nicer person you can become
a better listener you can become a
little more emotional like all of those
things and it's not just childhood and
it's not just adolescence and it's not
even just early adulthood or middle
adulthood there's not a point
in the entire
span of a life where people stop
learning and growing if they're open to
it
wow i want i want us to have a
conversation about each of those things
because i want all of them
i would love to have another
conversation sale you know i'm a huge
fan of khan academy and i'm a huge fan
of yours let's book it because i think i
think we're just getting started i mean
there's so many questions folks are
i'm trying to see if i could squeeze one
more in
let's see uh
this is a big one but from youtube the
lol a asks where does passion come from
i'm 31 and still trying to find my
passion i don't find anything
interesting enough to put my soul into
any thoughts there i have some thoughts
okay well you start with your thoughts
nana and ryan and this will be our good
a good last question what's your
thoughts my quick advice for bilal is
make space for exploration uh i had that
same angst when i was young i had good
jobs but they weren't my passion
but i had space for exploration and
through that space for exploration i was
able to find my
my true passion
okay uh that's great advice i agree with
you and when i was 31 i was crying and
crying on my living room couch not
knowing what i wanted to do with my life
literally i mean asked my husband the
the the couch was nearly salty with like
you know you could almost see the
precipitate of the salt on the surface
of the pillows um i was crying that much
and and i really like i really
sympathize with this feeling of like oh
my gosh i you know i'm trying to have a
passion but i don't know what it is and
for me it was you know giving myself a
little freedom but i think also it was
reflecting on what i had become
interested in in the past and when i
thought back to when i was 16 years old
i remembered that when i was 16 i went
to summer school and because my
parents who are very cheap like wouldn't
pay for anything until like their kids
could pay for it so i had saved up all
my money and the first time i could
afford to do anything over the summer
was when i was 16. so i got to choose
and i opened up that course catalog and
what did i choose i chose two classes
psychology
and non-fiction writing and that's
essentially all i do all day psychology
and nonfiction writing so i guess i
would suggest that if you're a 31 year
old who like me was maybe crying a lot
very honest written is that in addition
to giving yourself some space for
self-exploration and is um try to
recall in your life the times where you
were interested in things or you were
excited and you might be able to piece
together some of the puzzle and i kid
you not when i was 32 i just like i had
thought about i was like oh i'm
interested in psychology i'm interested
in writing i used to teach math that
must mean i'm pretty good at math or i
like math i don't know and i
think i should be a psychologist and
then i went to graduate school
wow and then you became angela duckworth
well
well then i learned a lot about
psychology i'll say that yeah i i
i think for me i would say that now my
work is my calling and it is who i am i
think about it all the time i think
about if i wake up in the middle of the
night i think about on sunday morning i
think about it on friday night and i
think that's what this 31 year old wants
they want that and it was a process i
don't want to say it happened you know
in a moment in time but but there was
you know a long period of struggle
and i do empathize with that and i have
a lot of hope for you because uh you
know
you too sal probably couldn't have
foreseen that this would be
your calling but it is um and callings
generally you know take a while to
develop and to
um deepen over time
oh that's that's incredible incredible
advice and angela i i think i'll commit
us we're going to have at least one more
conversation
so thank you so much for joining us uh
thanks everyone else for for joining us
uh as as you can tell we wish we could
do this for for a long time more uh but
we will it's good to end on a high point
of people wanting more uh so please join
us for future live streams uh tomorrow
if i'm correct i think we're gonna have
jim nandor from the university of
chicago the head of admissions there uh
so look forward to seeing all of y'all
tomorrow thanks angela
bye
you